bill gates uh just said recently that  omicron has worked better as a vaccine  than actual vaccines this is bill gates  the vaccine guy listen where would you  assess where we are today  in beating covet  19. well the  uh  you know sadly  the virus itself particularly the  the variant called omicron  uh is a type of vaccine that is it  creates both b b-cell and t-cell  immunity and it's done a better job of  getting out to the world population  than we have  with vaccines  first off get a comb second  who else  said this  if you're catching uh covet now you're  very likely catching omicron and the  vast majority of people have very little  symptoms according to the cdc according  to them not us you could argue that  omicron is responsible for reducing  deaths more than the vaccines